a la espera de la llegada de los tanques
donados por occidente Ucrania en medio
del duro invierno se defiende con los
viejos vehículos de combate que aún
posee y que datan de la extinta unión
soviética con problemas técnicos los
soldados esperan la llegada de los
leopard 2 prometidos por Alemania
puede haber problemas con la mecánica El
tanque a veces pierde aceite el motor
separa la máquina es vieja y a veces se
avería
pero no hay problema en cuanto al
terreno Por el que puede circular el
único pequeño problema puede ser el
barro del Don Bach
príncipe
cuando todo se derrite afecta a la
velocidad del tanque
problema
aunque aún deben esperar para usarlos y
deben someterse a un entrenamiento que
ya empezó en Polonia
nunca los he visto en la vida real solo
he visto tan
en internet está claro que nos tienen
que enseñar a usarlos creo que dos
semanas son más que suficientes para
aprender a manejarlos Lo principal es
que tienes que querer aprender
a casi un año del comienzo de la guerra
en el campo de batalla en la región de
donietsk los combates se escalan y el
fundador del Mercenario grupo Wagner al
Servicio del kremlin lanzó una amenaza
sobre el presidente ucraniano zelensky
desde la cabina de un avión militar
[Música]
bolodimir selenski hemos aterrizado
hemos bombardeado bahamut mañana
pilotaré un mig 29 si lo desea vamos a
encontrarnos en los cielos
si ganan tomen artiomobs si no avanzamos
ni Pro
mientras Ucrania sigue recibiendo ayudas
internacionales Noruega anunció 7.300
millones de dólares durante cinco años a
kiev el presidente bolodimir selensky
catalogó este gesto como una situación
sin precedentes